das ist wirklich verrückt jeden tag
verliert die atmosphäre unserer erde an
masse
denn sie ist undicht und gibt so
tonnenweise sauerstoff an den weltraum
ab nasa forschungsteams sind diesen
mysteriösen phänomenen jetzt auf der
spur und zwar mit mass raketen die
dieses rätsel endlich lüften sollen wie
kann es sein dass das relativ schwere
gas sauerstoff der erdanziehungskraft
trotzen kann welche rolle spielen die
polarlichter dabei wie viel sauerstoff
geht der erde wirklich verloren was
bedeutet dass wir das leben auf unserem
planeten die ersten spannenden
ergebnisse der nasa jetzt praktisch zum
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende wissenschafts videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
100 bis 1000 tonnen gas die fundieren
pro tag durch ein leck der erdatmosphäre
ins all hinaus das ist selbst für die
fachleute der nasa ein großes rätsel
denn bei sauerstoff handelt es sich um
ein eher schweres gas das eigentlich von
der schwerkraft der erde festgehalten
werden sollte dazu der nasa forscher
dass rowland um der erdanziehungskraft
zu entkommen müsste der sauerstoff etwa
die hundertfache energie aufbringen die
dieses gas normalerweise besitzt es
dürften daher nur winzige anteile des
sauerstoffs entweichen durch welche
prozesse kommt der sauerstoff also an
genügend energie um in diese höhen zu
gelangen
vor einiger zeit kamen forschungsteams
auf eine erste erklärung polarlichter
die wir vor allem als wunderschöne
leuchterscheinungen am ende kennen doch
polarlichter sind wohl auch in der lage
dem sauerstoff einen enormen energie
schub zu geben messungen konnten zeigen
dass sie sehr energiereiche teilchen mit
bringen wodurch sich die obere
atmosphäre aufheizt
diese hitze verleiht atmosphärischen
gasen dann offensichtlich so viel
energie dass sie ins all katapultiert
werden
so entstehen also richtige sauerstoff
von denen diese prozesse finden vor
allem in polen nähe und auf der
nachtseite der erde statt die
polarlichter kann man sich bei diesem
prozess ein bisschen so vorstellen wie
eine art fahrstuhl der dem
atmosphärischen sauerstoff dabei
behilflich ist aus zuströmen mesz
raketen sollen jetzt zeigen
ob dies auch auf der tagseite so abläuft
oder ob wir uns den prozess dort anders
vorzustellen haben das entsprechende
nasa projekt visions zwei läuft in
spitzbergen und von dort ist vor kurzem
eine erste mass rakete ins all gestattet
konkret sind die forschungsteams an den
teilchen strom und gas konzentration
interessiert die zeigen können ob solche
atmosphärischen fontänen auch auf der
tagseite der erde ausgestoßen werden und
dafür ist spitzbergen tatsächlich der
perfekte ort denn es liegt nahe der
sogenannten polaks diese zonen kann man
sich quasi so vorstellen wie ein polaris
einfallstor im erdmagnetfeld hier
dringen teilchen der sonnenwinde viel
weiter in die atmosphäre der erde vor
als in anderen zonen die nasa
forschungsteams vermuten dass genau an
diesen stellen besonders viel sauerstoff
in den weltraum entweicht und die mass
rakete hat jetzt erste daten geliefert
die diese annahme untermauern dazu dass
rowland
ich denke dass wir die atmosphärische
fontäne in den daten gesehen haben der
ionen ausstoß in diesem scheitelpunkt
der tagseite ist stetiger und hat eine
niedrigere energie als auf der
nachtseite zeitnah soll jetzt analysiert
werden welche unterschiede und
gemeinsamkeiten die beiden leckstellen
aufweisen was genau charakterisiert das
lag auf der nacht was genau
charakterisiert das lag auf der tagseite
der erde
aber was hat dieses lag die atmosphäre
für das leben auf unserem planeten zu
bedeuten entwarnung der sauerstoff wird
uns in nächster zeit wohl nicht ausgehen
die nasa geht davon aus dass uns die
atmosphäre bei den derzeitigen
verlustraten wohl noch milliarden von
jahren erhalten bleibt zudem gibt es
einen ausgleich und zwar durch die
biologischen prozesse wie etwa die
photosynthese der pflanzen
doch die aktuellen erkenntnisse führen
uns noch einmal deutlich vor augen dass
unsere atmosphäre eine entscheidende
rolle für unsere existenz spielt und so
können wir gar nicht verantwortungsvoll
genug mit ihr umgehen doch durch unseren
hohen co2 ausstoß erhöht sich natürlich
auch seinen anteil in der atmosphäre zu
dem holz der wälder ab und reduzieren
damit den pflanzenbestand der ja auch
für sauerstoff nachschub gesorgt wie man
aber eine welt sogar von unbewohnbar im
bewohnbar umgestaltet das erfahrt ihr
hier unbedingt draufklicken venus
terraforming einen
in den wolken von raum zeit lockt der
zukunft der kanal geht gerade so richtig
ab also unbedingt abonnieren ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran